Hola Pues el recibimiento fue desde ayer
cuando López Obrador acudió al
aeropuerto a recibir al nuevo aeropuerto
a recibir a biden Y juntos se
trasladaron en este automóvil llamado la
bestia hasta el hospedaje hasta el hotel
donde se encuentra instalado el Joe
biden después López Obrador fue a
recibir a esta esta tarde a Justin
trudeau Primer Ministro de Canadá y
regresó a Palacio Nacional pues ya ya
está en curso la la reunión entre Joe
biden y López Obrador esta tarde llegó
el presidente de Estados Unidos
acompañado de su esposa Gil biden y
también López Obrador con su esposa
Beatriz Gutiérrez Müller le dieron la
recepción se entonaron los signos de
cada país y están también en una sesión
fotográfica en una charla privada y en
punto de las 17 horas local dan inicio a
los trabajos de las delegaciones los
trabajos formales en las que como ya se
ha mencionado los temas de seguridad
migración cambio climático y cooperación
para el desarrollo serán clave en esta
en esta visita en este encuentro
bilateral previo a la cena que habrá
esta noche en Palacio Nacional ya con la
presencia de Justin trudeau es decir los
tres mandatarios y sus esposas en una
cena que habrá ahí mismo en Palacio
Nacional y dar pie mañana a ya la
reunión trilateral que será Este martes
bueno Mario nos has adelantado ya que ha
sucedido en este Palacio Y qué puede
suceder Hay algún otro tipo de acto
planeado para hoy y cuál es el plan para
los siguientes días en esta cumple
trilateral
Sí si en principio previo a esta reunión
entre los dos presidentes hace unos
instantes las esposas de cada uno han
dado un mensaje ahí en Palacio Nacional
un mensaje conjunto un posicionamiento
en el que impulsan el respeto a la
democracia el valor que tiene la
democracia para las sociedades actuales
y también la educación como un Pilar
fundamental para mejorar también la vida
de los pueblos se pronunciaron también
en contra del racismo y la xenofobia y
pues valoraron estos lazos que unen a
México y Estados Unidos en estos 200
años de relación Ya para la Cumbre
trilateral insisto participarán los
ministros de cada uno de los rubros que
se tocarán en esta mesa de diálogo y
posteriormente habrá una reunión
bilateral entre López Obrador y Justin
esto es la tarde de mañana para concluir
Pues esta Cumbre que se da en Llamar la
Cumbre de Los tres amigos